foreign
is waiting in Denver Colorado Sarah
welcome to the show
absolutely how can we help today
so my fiance and I are going to get
married a little bit later this year and
we're talking about buying a house
I actually was married previously and
not our divorce and he is now
um in the picture and I have had a
significant amount of assets
um over time like we have similar
salaries now but I've just had a decent
time to like pile mine up and so
although from like a family and marriage
perspective we do want to take like what
you guys could just talk about of
merging our finances and treating it as
like an us uh you know group and and how
do we buy a house and so forth but I
also bring like quite a bit of cash and
like brokerage accounts and so forth I
could use for either the down pavement
or even like buying a house outright and
so I was kind of curious your advice
about when one person has a significant
amount it's like you will protect
yourself I mean I did go through a
divorce before but at the same time I
don't want to go into my marriage like
thinking of the quote-unquote worst case
scenario
um well that's a it's a reasonable thing
to be thinking about because of you know
the hurt you felt in the past divorces
one of the most difficult things a
person can go through and it can scar
you when it comes to the way you view
money and of course we talk about this
is we this is our money once you're
married combine all the accounts
um and the only time we would recommend
a prenup is if you are coming in with
you know astronomical assets compared to
the other person and it's more to keep
the crazy family at Bay versus a
distrust in the other person so what
kind of assets are we talking about give
give us some numbers
so I have about 2 million between like
retirement accounts and I had sold my
previous house that I owned with my
ex-husband and walked away
um with a bit of cash from that and so
like I'm sitting on just from like a
cash standpoint over half a million
dollars and then on this side do I want
to buy the next house do I want to put
that in the market not just rush into a
decision he on the other hand probably
has more like five hundred thousand
dollars so again neither one of us is
like at any hurt from a financial
perspective but when it comes to you
know buying a house that was not
something he was like initially planning
for so it's more tied up in like
brokerage and socks and with the stock
market going down it's like how do we
get to something where like I could buy
our house but I want him to feel like he
has skin in the game but at the same
time yeah like
we totally want to try to merch but yeah
but here's the deal time keeping mine
Sarah Sarah I'm sorry to interrupt but I
think we really got to dive in here
what are you most afraid of
I don't think you're calling for
strategy I could be wrong are you
calling for strategy about how we merge
all this and how we do this or are you
worried about something
I think it's more like I
Sarah don't edit you're trying to edit
and listen I get it but we're here to
help and if you just tell me what you're
feeling right now we can help faster
tell me stop editing what are you
thinking that you didn't say what are
you worried about
the main thing I would be worried about
is like if for some reason the marriage
shouldn't work out like I on one hand I
would want to make sure that this
significant amount of money is still
being recognized as mine especially so
all right so stop so stop so stop okay
the answer to the question is you are
worried that the marriage is not going
to work out
the money stuff is secondary
do you understand I would say I'm
worried about being stupid honestly if I
was gonna like get really to the to the
butt of it okay which is not going to
work out I think there's an element of
like I don't want to be the stupid
person
wait a second what would have to be true
and I want you to give me a specific
answer what would have to be true for
you to be stupid
yeah I would have to go sideways for
some reason and the marriage would not
have to work out the marriage is going
to work
if there's also a secondary opponent of
like I'm wanting him to not feel like
like I bought stuff I had the money at
the beginning and therefore it's
quote-unquote now now we're getting
there
Sarah now we're getting there
you have more money than he does and
that freaks you out a little bit and
you're worried about it that's really
what I'm hearing so this is pre-marriage
counseling this is a good old-fashioned
steak and candlelight dinner and you
look at him and you go I'm worried that
you're gonna feel this way and this way
and this way because when we bring our
finances together I'm bringing more the
table than you do you feel that way
George I think this is a communication
relationship pre-marital therapy thing
and get this thing solved and get this
out of your head and then when we merge
the finances we walk the baby steps out
we live that way I think it's gonna be
fine yeah I don't see it as a skin in
the game or adding up who's bringing
what to the marriage it's about
commitment it's about Unity it's about
shared vision and I think once you focus
on that instead of the numbers it will
give you some peace I'm gonna gift you
guys Financial Peace University because
I think it will give you confidence in
your own Futures together as a newlywed
couple hang on the line Austin will give
that to you wishing you the best